دبابه اثنان المانيه الصنع وتعتبر دبابه
القتال الرائده على مستوى العالم مجهزه
بخزان وقود يمكنها من ان تسير مسافه تصل
الى 500 كلم دون الحاجه الى تزويدها
بالوقود ثانيا وتبلغ سرعتها القصوى 68 كلم
في الساعه تم تصميمها للتحرك بسرعه في
جميع الطرقات بما فيها الوعره والاختراق
دروع
الالمانيه
في ساحه المعركه كيف تطالب بتجديد اسطول
دباباتها القديمه وباضافه اثنان
في المرتبه الثانيه لكن
تمجزوا عنها بمحركها القوي المدعه الفا
دبابه منها يمتلكها 15 جيشا اوروبيا مثل
المانيا واسبانيا وبولندا وفنلندا يمكن ان
يسمح امتلاكه اوكرانيا لها بالبدء في
الهجوم بعد الجمود الحاصل خلال الاشهر
القليله الماضيه ويبقى العدد الذي يمكن ان
يحصل عليه الجيش اللبناني ووليد مفتاح
تزويده ب 100 دبابه منها قد يكون كافيا
لاحداث فريق على الارض حسب راي بعض
المحللين العسكريين الغربيين